well I'm pretty much broke on the let's
play videos i suppose i can get back to
this little castle thing which hopefully
should be done in one other episode but
i'm really not sure at this point since
i still need to do the course of gardens
and I've no exact idea how that's going
to turn out I have to say like this
castle like overall was really just one
of those other random ideas that I
really just felt like I wanted to do but
then again the issue is that i just took
much more time than I expected actually
I was very nearly that like when I just
started out with this I figured I would
be able to do it in like two hours or
something like that but five hours
further and I still have no idea like
how I'm even going to finish it so yeah
that might become a bit of a problem I
do have to say by the way it there's
like not too much happening I suppose
here just adding the wings which are
going to be similar to the main part of
the castle one thing that you probably
have noticed at this point I don't know
if I have talked about that in day in
the past I may have actually I'm not
sure about that but the colors they are
slightly changed it's not going to be
completely white it's not going to be a
complete fairy tale sort of console like
that though of course this is a
fairytale castle note no amount of money
in the world can buy you such a enormous
castle or like no way that you can even
make it work somehow this really fits up
like right up there with all night the
crazy ideas that architects have had in
the past and like never even turn out to
be real so that's a bit of a thing but
yeah that's the basic sort of promised
that I started out with I wanted to make
a really beautiful call sort of
fairytale white castle and just go all
for eclectic and unrealistic on it but
yeah i just turned out that having
everything be white really kills the
depth in roller coaster three since you
don't really have to like shadows that
are too good and the sort of overall
look is comprised of individual objects
that don't really aren't really used in
the things that they are supposed to be
used for so i really just had to get
some color differences in to make it
look a tiny bit better get the depth out
there and actually perhaps also make it
look a tiny bit more interesting exhibit
really really called when you really
have that one hundred percent white look
which sometimes can look really amazing
and stunning but i don't know if i was
quite going to pull it off in roller
coaster can three so i suppose it's also
a bit of a more safe thing to do plus i
think it does still contrast enough with
the lower lower parts of the building my
just has the darkest tone text is so
that should be fine in the end i think
is really just this is just a crazy
amount of second custom scenery over
here to sort of get the desired look
basically what i wanted to try was to
get those large fancy decorated pillars
there is a lot of vertical action when
you have gothic buildings many pillars
and wall supports on the sides of
buildings so that's also something i
really wanted to get in on this building
and then there were obviously the arches
as well it's just that it's pretty hard
to make it actually work and that's why
there may have also been some more of
experimenting with stuff and try on
error that I'm then I maybe would have
liked in this building but then again
it's it's alright i suppose in the end
it sort of worked out except for the
main tower i'm still not too sure about
that main tower it's probably gonna
study because it's it's all right i
suppose but it doesn't really work too
well yet not to not to really mention
that you know this is all nice and to
empty that I'm building this castle but
no idea what is actually going to be
supposed to be used for there were many
people have recommended to use the
castle in the last play park no way in a
thousand [ __ ] years that's can even
come close to happening I'm very sorry
but it's just so incredibly huge I can't
fit that in the in the park like in any
way possible maybe even why do then the
entire Dutch area combined it would be
way too ginormous it really won't work
out it would be absolutely terrible this
is just a fantasy structure yeah not to
mention that realistically no theme park
and even afford to built this building
so that might be a bit of an issue too
so yeah that's why I really don't think
I can do much with it the idea at the
moment of what I'm really going to do
with it is just a take just finish it
make
look nice it takes some fancy pictures
of it probably turn it maybe even into a
separate video just quickly showing it
off in a simpler a similar way to how i
did it with the cable car ride
thingamajig I mean that was pretty all
right too I could probably do something
like that to mainly just take some cool
pictures and make some cool little films
and then delete it from existence and
escape it as a sort of learning
experience it was really nice to see
like whatever things you could use for
whatever functions in buildings like
really the main street sets are so
incredibly versatile when you really get
down to it like there is so much of the
main street to roof support piece in
here as the most random of things really
like I'm pretty sure I actually use the
roof support piece from the main streets
at to both as these supports as well as
the capital of the pillars over there
the pillars from Main Street 9 which I
still think are the most user-friendly
and best-looking pillars out there of
any of the RCT three pillars ever made
only problem with them is really they
are 4h and you can't really change
anything about that so you stuck with
what they're like but then again that's
that's all right since you know with a
bit of working around it and adding some
roof pieces that can usually work for
larger pillars as well not to mention
that you can stick you can stack them
I've seen people do that I just feel
like it does look a bit wonky so I would
like to avoid that and whatever way
whenever way I really can and then all
of the little details and decorations
are also from the main streets you
should mainly since you can obviously
see the main street 9 i'm not entirely
sure what that is i'm pretty sure it is
a corner space which does have the
little circles and decorations on it
which sort of makes the wall look a tiny
bit less boring than just straight
bricks with nothing on it really and by
the way you may have noticed that this
was just one of wait no no first I need
to talk about what you may have actually
noticed see I guess I get ahead of
myself again there is a like blue bar
the top of my screen at the moment
which usually shouldn't be there it's
just that for once I felt like I could
record with them shadowplay which turned
out to be a pretty nice thing but I
still need to figure this entire thing
out because I thought I had all all
these settings uprights but it cut the
entire time lapse into videos of 20
minutes but that means at this point I
had like 11 videos of 20 minutes is
something like that or it was like half
that I'm not entirely sure i mean like i
have three four five I don't know like
aids videos up here way too many videos
for a little over to our time lapse so
that was a bit annoying and there's
obviously the blue thing over there
which I might also crop out but then
again then voila co second three
wouldn't be completely full like good
anymore so yeah I'm just too used to
perhaps the only real downside to
perhaps is that it just creates huge
uncompressed avi files so that's just a
big downside I mean with just one
terabyte and st. just one terabyte
sounds really bad but not going to
easily make that with fraps that's a bit
of the problem right there by the way
this was also pretty funny like gothic d
like gothic details basically it's
something that you don't really have it
well acoustic in three too much and it's
something that I really needed to have
for both this building but also like
some of the earlier builds that I try
like a Romanian castle and the cathedral
as well and it's just really hard to get
around actually having gothic details
but it does turn out that the Disney
sets which does have those smaller roof
pieces that are supposed to be used at
the top of a tower for a disney castle
work pretty damn well for those little
gothic support things and then there's
also there's always the little things
that you could just add around pretty
much anything like those white balls and
make anything look alright in that sort
of respect though my favorite of the
little doodads that you can pretty much
use anywhere to make things look good
are probably from the efteling set you
may have noticed that that I use the
little peeks from pat's up the links
that very often they have like these
little pigs with small Spears and
triangular stuff on them and they
are very small you can pretty much use
them to cap off any sort of spire that
you have anywhere or put them on fences
even put them on the lamppost it's
really amazing to just have those really
small pieces very simple that you can
just add on to things to make them look
a tiny bit more detailed and the life is
just nice overall so that's also what
sort of helped me in those little
cathedral and these little gothic I mean
pillars and stuff and I must say yeah
it's mainly in the details that this
building I suppose is going to look nice
eventually I mean I'm still really not
too sure about the way that the main
tower looks and the fact that it works
the rest of the building though I must
say that from am from the front it does
still look pretty pretty good i'm pretty
happy about it I'm just not still not
sure about the tower but otherwise I
feel pretty confident about the
building's definitely a few things that
you can always change make it make it
look a tiny bit detailed in some ways
and perhaps also change the shape of the
building overall I was at first planning
to also have some smaller tower ish
looking things on the sides of the wings
as well but that just really didn't work
out in the end it just it would be at
our vest and that was something that I
really wanted to avoid with this
building like as soon as you get into
the the more fantasy ish themes it
really soon starts to be a tower vest
and that's really something i didn't
want over here but i think i should
about rounded up actually no I still
have a tiny bit of time left over here
I'm actually gonna cut this off at about
eleven plus minutes and then save the
rest for the last time lapse which if it
really becomes way too large then I
might just um cut that up and add some
pieces to that and make four videos of
this palace but that's really not the
planning I don't want to spend too much
time on it I just have to at some point
in the future cut back to this thing
actually finish the gardens get my [ __ ]
together and actually do what I'm
supposed to do also speaking of those
towers at this point I was ending those
towers though I am pretty sure that I
did remove those in the end in favor of
not having them which was a bit of a
bummer because they looks awesome it's
just that for the castle as a whole I
felt like they were
really good but any case that's gonna be
it for today so thank you for watching
and I'll see you guys next time
you